still there's currently a distrust of
big pharma in the public maybe this is
something i'd love to hear your comment
on
um
there's the stress of science when it's
tangled up with corporations and
government institutions like we've
talked about
but you have they have to be entitled to
achieve scale
oversight and to achieve the kind of
skill that pfizer has been able to
accomplish
how can pfizer regain the public trust
how can you regain the public trust do
you think not regain but sort of take
steps
to increase the public trust
reputation is something that
you can lose in buckets but you can earn
it back in drops
and
once you lost it
you are going to take a lot of effort to
bring it back
and the pharmaceutical industry lost it
it's clear that the reputation of the
industry
in
the last decade
was on the lowest that we have seen
ever and
for there are many reasons for that
but clearly there are reasons that are
related also with the behavior of the
industry
that needed to change and i'm hopeful
that uh
very few
will disagree that the industry is a
very different interest right now
that being said
i truly believe
that
if there is one lesson that stands out
from the main lessons that we learned
during covet
is the power of science in the hands of
the private sector
i think
it was the private sector
that came with solutions with diagnostic
tests when we didn't have
solutions with respirators when we
didn't have
solutions with treatments solutions with
vaccines
and
i think that demonstrated very clearly
to the world the value
of
thriving
life sciences sector private lifestyle
sector to society
that also affected very positively the
reputation
both of the sector and of isa
i'm not going to make the mistake to
consider given
i'm not making to make the mistake that
because our occupation is high
that will remain so
we need to earn it every day every day
with everything we do
with everything we say with the way we
behave
and i hope that we'll rise to this
occasion and we'll do that
you